inzwischen gibt es in deutschland sogar
börsennotierte pflege ketten ketten
sowie mcdonald's nur noch schlechtere
messen martin klempnow ist
vorstandsvorsitzender so einer kette
herr klempenow altenpflege ist dass der
neue wachstumsmarkt absolut sie müssen
sich das so vorstellen herr welke wir
nehmen den ranzigen rohstoff alte
menschen und machen daraus was
wunderbares geld weiterhin weitergehen
macht man abgang louis b aber die hatten
in den teer schnell doch die buchkinder
die brauchen kalender senioren sind
deutschlands einziger nachwachsender
rohstoff bis 2030 haben wir einen bedarf
von 160.000 pflegeplätzen ich wieder
obwohl die zahl gern noch mal 160 zeugen
mussten orgasmus abwarten
aber wenn man damit so viel geld
verdient warum verdienen die
pflegekräfte dann so wenig papperlapapp
ich kann es nicht mehr hören
altenpfleger verdienen nichts
das stimmt doch janisch langsamer wie
maike kohl-richter ja es geht hier um
business und geht um effizienz hier ein
beispiel frühstück es wichtig keine
frage aber warum sind frühstück und aufs
klo gehen immer eigentlich drei
verschiedene brachten
der ist doch quatsch es gibt so viel
einsparpotenzial ja frage braucht
wirklich jedes zimmer eine eigene dusche
antwort nein wenn ihr war stark ist dann
fahren wir gerne ins gewerbegebiet
nebenan und da gibt es schon die comfort
plus wäsche mit unterbodenschutz und
heißwachs fälligen kosten extra und dazu
gibt es ja auch noch die payback punkte
ach es ist einfach ein absoluter traum
branche
das einzige problem ist dass viele
senioren sich ja leider so ärgerlich
schritt halten und damit unnötig den
umzug ins heim verzögern
ja aber auch da helfen wir gerne nach
wir nennen das kundenakquise
herr welke jetzt mal so nebenbei gesagt
sie sehen ja auch nicht mehr ganz
taufrisch aus bitte ich hätte dafür
sehen zdf promi rabatt doppelzimmer mit
carmen nebel
nein ich hab mal positiv aber zwei
mitarbeiter vorbeigeschickt ja die
können sie ja gerne mitnehmen nach der
sendung ist nicht nötig bis später hat
den club vielen dank
martin klempnow
[Applaus]
[Musik]